and the center at the center of this
book is a story about a scientific
Renaissance and the fact is that much to
my surprise
long before Timothy Leary came along in
the 60s which is with the 60s is kind of
branded psychedelics for most of the
culture and from perhaps many people in
the room but but long before Timothy
Leary had his first transformative
experience by a pool in Cuernavaca on
psilocybin in 1960 there had been a
decade of really fertile research trying
to figure out what these amazing
molecules were and could do and then
trying to understand how they might be
applied therapeutically and so they went
through a whole you know set of changing
paradigms and they gradually kind of
coalesced around the idea that these
drugs could be very useful in treating
addiction there's a lot of work on
alcoholism in the 50s and in treating
depression and anxiety and and there was
you know I don't think people realize
but there were a thousand peer-reviewed
papers about LSD and psilocybin before
1965 and there was something like 40,000
research subjects six international
conferences on LSD it was considered a
psychiatric wonder drug
for for among many people in the
psychiatric establishment and this
research died F basically had faded out
after the counterculture embraced
psychedelics and there was a there was a
moral panic around them and lots of
horror stories many of which you know
we've all heard and and I believed
frankly most of them when I started this
work and then the research resumed and
this happens I mean I'm making it sound
way too simple it took a lot of work to
get it off the ground to get the FDA and
the DEA tour people here that were
involved and there are people in this
room who helped push it forward against
tremendous odds but beginning in the
late 90s you once again have this
resumption of serious and I'm talking
about rigorous controlled trials of
psilocybin especial
because LSD was still you know for two
reasons LSD was much more controversial
much more likely to run into a political
buzzsaw and psilocybin which most
politicians have never heard of and and
also that frankly LSD takes too long you
know you'd have to have pay overtime to
all your therapists if their guiding an
LSD trip whereas psilocybin kind of fits
into the workday pretty well so so there
have been a series of trials and they've
been very you know there's a lot of
really good data it's still preliminary
and there are many more steps there's
more Phase two trials there phase three
trials that have to happen before the
FDA will approve it but that's the path
were on and and by the way that path was
marked by maps the organization and Rick
Doblin who made a study of the who made
a study he went to Harvard to get a PhD
in government or administration so he on
so he could really understand what you
had to do to get a drug through the FDA
and he charted the path that both
psilocybin and MDMA we're getting
psychedelic here